when i was looking on instagram you do
these videos where you show yourself
without makeup
now that's a brave thing to do in
hollywood right why are we doing that is
that to say to women look don't be
fooled by television and don't be fooled
of the concept of beauty these are
professional makeup artists this is what
real people look like is that is there a
message in that i don't know if i think
of it that way but yeah it's a little
bit of the man behind the curtain
i mean this is reality this is how it
starts and this is the fake part that
ends you know that you end up with i
always love your honesty when i read
these articles about you and you said
hey you know there were a couple of
years i got caught up in the getting
fillers and all this other [ __ ] and you
said [ __ ] that i'm taking that i don't i
don't want to succumb to this hollywood
uh image of what's attractive and all of
that and i like that you you talk about
that stuff and you talk about getting
older in hollywood it's it's
yeah you can't chase it you can't chase
it and then when you try to chase it
it doesn't work it's like it's that that
is no
bueno it doesn't work
so you gotta just relax into it and i
just directed this commercial and all of
the characters were very old and it's
about you know when you know when you
love something you stick with it it was
it's for a whine and um
you asked people what's what what's what
do you like about getting older
well i know what i want and i know um
and it's kind of true it's like i feel
much more comfortable even sitting here
i know we know each other but
everything is just oh well [ __ ] it i'm
feeling you know just more comfortable
in my skin
i mean not all my skin i don't like
you're in incredible shape though i mean
i'm i was watching the one video you're
doing a kickboxing workout i'm like [ __ ]
that it's impressive i do work out yeah
i do i play tennis that's one of the
things i love i do um i just got this
incredible weight machine and
i do you know i don't know how to use it
but i still like to look at it and try
it